[Musique]
c'est le président de l'espace sud qui
est dans son caddie ce matin bonjour aux
jeunes larcher bonjour on joue à dos de
l'amendé n'est qu'un aspect du jour
merci d'être avec nous une histoire qui
remonte à la surface et qui vous
concerne vous espace communautaire
les récentes tensions entre la société
martiniquaise 18h10 si on rappelle que
l'asm me réclame une ardoise de 11
millions d'euros aux prestataires de
services de la zone kacem pour de l'eau
fournie aux communes du lamentin et de
saint joseph
or eugène larcher orne le 6e qui
n'existe plus et dont vous avez repris
la compétence mans dernier s'était
engagé à payer cette eau en lieu et
place et de la cacem et d'eau d'ici et
miss est consac moma et le sud qu'à
payer pour bloquer yoka une faute france
épicé joseph qu'elle sordide histoire
moralement acceptable oui ce dernier il
faut déjà faire l'historique ou qu'on a
eu cette compétence c'est parce que le
six étaient seize communes quand la
cacem a pris la compétence eau
assainissement les deux communes
le lamentin et saint joseph ont joué à
la casse et à me verser 14 communes est
le nord à partir de 2015 a aussi pris la
compétence à la trinité et robert ont
rejoint cap nord près alors là il
restait les douze communes du sud
appelait m les douze communes de la
communauté d'agglomération de l'espace
sud périmètre identique
alors la communauté se substitue aux
syndicats alors le syndicat est dissous
mais ça on le savait début 2015
depuis on le savait depuis 2015 et où on
a continué à fonctionner toute l'année
2016 sachant que le syndicat se
raidissent ou puisque nous l'avons nous
n'avons récupéré la compétence qu'au 1er
janvier 2017
alors aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qui se passe
il y avait eu un contrat qu'a été signé
dans lequel en 2015 entre le 6 et l'asm
est l'une des clauses du contrat de 12
ans
ce qui est énorme nous
alors l'une des classes et la tique 55.2
qui dit au cas où la cacem et audhuy dc
wafers raid payer c'est le 6 qui
prendrait le relais équipe est là à sa
place donc aujourd'hui les salua qui
fait et c'est ça qui fait parce que en
ces 4000 aussi ce que le 6 à payer alors
que j'adore chez kadhafi
il n'y a pas de discussion vous n'avez
quand j'avais expliqué tout sa jeunesse
j'ai 12 ans alors aujourd'hui 2015 a été
payée mais je reviendrai là dessus et de
mélèzes et me réclame 2016 et 2017 2016
et 2017 et plus de 10 millions
conformément au contrat signé en forme
et man au contrat signé entre les deux
mais n'y a jamais eu de convention entre
eux ni entre audi signé entre la cacem
et l'asm n'a jamais de conscient il y
avait le vote
d'où une vente au goût doux vers le
lamentin et vers le saint joseph mais
est ce que vous comprenez pourquoi on
s'y perd alors la question est ce que
vous voulez dénoncer tout ce que tout
cela vous en tant que président de la
communauté d'agglomération l'espace sud
qui a payé en 2015 et en 2016 pourrait
perdre 2017 le succès a payé en 2015 pas
je ne l'aurais pas d'accord le délégué
de l'espace
nous sommes bien d'accord pour la
précision de vous entendre
là vous êtes en train de me dire que les
habitants des anses d'arlet du diamant
du saint-esprit de dios paye de l'eau
les gens ou et les habitants du sud
on payait 2015 pour le lamentin et la
cacem près alors quand aujourd'hui la
halle à l'asm vie rude là mais j'ai dit
non que l'espace sud ne paiera pas on ne
paye a pas pas un centime ni 2016
ni 2017 parce que les gens du lamentin
pelo à raison de 0 98 à eau d'ici ainsi
que ceux de saint joseph
alors l'eau d'ici récupère l'argent je
ne veux pas dire qu'il y à un
enrichissement sans cause
mais ça s'apparente à cela puisque le
n'est pas piller alors aujourd'hui pour
récupérer les 4 millions 6 nous avons
tenu une réunion agglo président de la
cacem le président de l'eau d'ici le
président de cap nord et moi même sommes
engagés nous sommes environ la somme
n'était pas bon pour réparer le
règlement des 4 millions 6 2 4 millions
6 puisque le le lot d'ici ne veut pas
payer l'eau facturé à 87 centimes d'euro
vous voulez vélo à 45 d'ici à moins cher
alors du coup qu'est ce qui s'est passé
il fallait bien qu'on récupère cet
argent puisque les entreprises viennent
vers nous parce qu'on a trouvé un
déficit de 23 millions d'euros
c'est pas su 2 environnement et sceller
spacieux alors là comment va ta sortir
jeunes en somme nous sommes réunis alors
avec le président de la cacem qui
s'engagent et a happé 20 centimes d'euro
au disque et accepté de payer 45 euros
ça fait 60 centimes d'euro et à 27
centaines d'euros car nous perdons cap
no et moi même ce qui est l'espace sud
ce qui donne un montant de 1 million
soit 7000 euros on soutenir lâchant
consommation concerne 2015 nous comptons
voilages map à sa façon et stands mais
ce n'est pas quelqu'un de moitié en deux
moitiés de l'emploi dans le sud n'est
pas assez yoro traoré puis le comité
citoyen sud notamment
scemama issus de l'a400 que le cas pedro
bad bad gones l'équipe a quand même
sorti 10 cassotti dans le nord plutôt et
et puis je dis joue quand même préféré
de tout la guitare de l'argent yoplait
et de l'eau mais - man paca pays de
l'eau ni malaga samedi barreaux d'ici
mapa cabedo 2016 m'abattre ab blood 2010
elle est spacieuse les
à l'unanimité ont voté sur principe oui
mais les affaires économiques mais il
connaissait de l'asm
nick attaqué parce que moi je t'ai nous
se creusent la matraque dit non ses
classes au total à l'article 355 points
2 je dénonce sociaux n'est pas normal
qu'une collectivité puisque le relais
d'une autre collectivité est payé pour
elles ça c'est non sacem à la normale
d'autant plus que nous n'avons pas
d'argent mais nous n'avons pas d'argent
pas ce que nous allons trouver un trou
béant
oui alors justement revient là dessus
vous sembliez vous sembliez jeunes
larcher gt lors de cette conférence de
pression ce que vous parliez de ces de
ces troubles que vous suscitez par cet
abysse de 23 millions d'euros dans les
caisses du 6 mai at elle qui est partie
c'est l'eau pour les communes du sud
le budget n'a pas été voté l'an dernier
ni le compte administratif dossiers
transmis au préfet on en est où
aujourd'hui est ce que la chambre
régionale des comptes a produit son
rapport
alors c'est vrai que le nous avons
transmis le dossier au préfet nous avons
transmis le dossier à la chambre
régionale des comptes puisque je les 23
millions d'euros parce qu'il ya une clé
de répartition entre le nord et le sud
le nord et 19% nous c'est 80 un bon sens
sur ces 23 millions nous pour nous c'est
18 millions 6 0 pagnol nous avons écrit
nous avons demandé à l'état de
participer
ne serait-ce qu'à raison de 7 à 12 ans
nous n'avons pas reçu de riverains du
temps ça fait plaisir maintenant où ça
fait un petit moment que nous sommes en
attente d'une réponse
mais nous n'avons braquo et puis nous
nous avons aussi travaillé avec la
chambre régionale
nous avons demandé à ce qu'il y ait un
plan de redressement un plan de
redressement de réponse réponse vaut de
la gaude administratif mettez les 18
millions au budget on peut pas mettre
les 18 millions b j
on ne pouvait pas les mettre sinon votre
et un budget des excuses avait décidé de
porter plainte dans cette affaire
eugène larcher je dénonce je ne porte
pas plainte
je n'ai pas porté plainte mais payant
lui de porter plainte en se dirigeant du
6/9
non pas du tout je dis ce qu'il faut
faire jeudi que le l'état est au coin je
mets des ventes est monsieur viol viol
dont il ya trésorier payeur général qui
reçoit les deux villes est facturé qui
gère les comptes et qu'ils regardent
l'école le lexique ce personne n'a
signalé cela et à des délibérations qui
sont prises
il y à ddd vous étiez à bridgewater ne
s'est jamais terminé 7e du 6 vous ne
serez jamais jamais il ya d'autres élus
qui siègent vous étiez au courant
monsieur le maire déshonore et je
n'étais pas au courant même les élus qui
siégeaient alex xmmd et qui aujourd'hui
siège à la communauté d'agglomération de
l'espace sud sont très étonnées la peau
cité par exemple arnaud rené-corail le
maire des 3 ide au commerce monsieur
monsieur larcher
vous êtes un élu vous êtes président d'
espace communautaire est ce que vous
parce que vous pensez que ça peut être
des sens de la part pour aller pour les
administrés pour les contribuables
martiniquais pour les 6,3 et martinique
est de savoir qui a des sommes qui
disparaissent comme ça dans la nature et
que on reste en matant ne porte pas
plainte
ce qui n'est pas décent c'est que le but
2015 on savait go et dissolution du six
puisqu'il ya un arrêté du préfet mais ça
aurait pu avoir fait le ménage avant de
prendre pouvait faire le ménage on
pouvait le base engager de dépenses en
2006 au contraire donc il ya sothys
chaussons et via centif
il ya donc attentif il y il y à ça alors
je crois que moi je ne dis pas que qu'il
s'agirait de l'incompétence ou je ne
sais pas mais je dirais fait qu'il y
avait fait qu'il y a des faits qu'il y à
des faits qui sont là et qui disent
parce que là aujourd'hui
nous ne pouvons pas nous ne pouvons pas
et veste here
nous ne pouvons même pas faire des
travaux nous ne pouvons même pas payer
des entreprises va il ya des entreprises
qui viennent et contre la montre et à
montrer
justement j'ai marché est ce qu'un
opérateur unique de l'eau en martinique
serait la solution c'est que les trois
présidents de l'espace communautaire
semble semble être d'accord pour aller
vers cette voie c'est daniel nous sommes
des gens non éduqués déjà créé cette
structure unique mais ça a foiré beau
des raisons assez opaque
oui oui c'est compliqué mais là
aujourd'hui puisqu'on l'a fait pour les
déchets oui le transport il ya là c'est
évident et on l'a fait pour le transport
on pouvait aussi faire boulot mais j'ai
vu leur dossier en main nous allons
crier mieux que unique de l'eau puisque
les deux autres présidents sont d'abord
le lot d'ici est d'abord et aussi il
faut associer la ctm puisque la ctm aviv
et à une usine alors nous allons à ce
sujet tout le monde pour créer une
structure unique de l'eau c'est vers là
tiens ça ne va pas régler tous les
problèmes parce que nous avons trouvé
des réseaux sol est on a trouvé et il ya
beaucoup de travaux à faire
il y a encore de l'avenir dans les
grosses villes où il y a beaucoup à
faire ça pas résoudre le voleur ça va
résoudre seul problème c'est qu'il y ait
un prix unique de l'eau sur l'ensemble
du territoire les chercheurs notent de
la matinée sinon nous aimerions nous
aimerions réglé dans un premier temps
tous les petits problèmes qui se posent
qui salissent au niveau des toits
communauté et se retrouvent eux pour
crier sa tenue merci beaucoup aux jeunes
archers présents dans l'espace une
version à boîte et dans son caddie